alte alter das wirten highscore das wird
ein welt score das wird ein world record
zickig dieses dings leute hier ich
möchte hier nicht irgendwie mich
strafbar machen aber alter was geht denn
mit mir ab alte halle ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren ipad-app die ich heute mit euch
spielen wollte und zwar heißt die app
barcoo car chase mit simeon leiter
glaube ich ich habe heute noch gar
nichts gegessen aber das interessiert ja
ich glaube ich gar nicht weil ich werde
jetzt direkt ein neues game anfang ein
highscore ist 8 sekunden und erstmal das
spielprinzip ist
ich muss hier vor der polizei wegfahren
die mich hier verfolgt und ich kann wenn
ich auf dem linken bild nicht auf dem
linken bild schirm drücke fahre ich
einen linkskurve und auf der rechten
seite fahre ich eine rechtskurve ich hab
das ganze auf dem handy sehr oft
gespielt und bin mit dieser taktik immer
ganz zufrieden
wer sich erst mal links um die mauer
herum fahren das ist meine taktik dass
ich erst mal so um dieses mal schild
hier rumfahren und dann wenn ich hier
eine rechtskurve fahre fahre ich nämlich
genau um diese polizeiwagen sie das
richtig dieses laster immer herzlich
denkt dieses video alter probiert auch
immer mal so ein paar neue taktiken
jemals ein bisschen schlangenlinien
fahren ein bisschen
zeig euch jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen
die welt in spa fahre ich jetzt mal hier
um dann haben wir so ein paar parkplätze
ist halt alles sondern so einen
supermarkt da vorne ist auch schon das
ende
ich weiß gar nicht ob es da mehr als nur
faktum wenn ich schaffe durch diese
parklücke zu driften bin ich echt dass
breaking batmobil ich will durch diese
eine parklücke da irgendwie driften
können das glattal liegt durch
schwertwal die metroid irgendwie irre
weil ich glaube ich muss einfach viel
früher einlenken damit das auch besser
das ist mein einziges
also ich will ja nicht dadurch fahren
hier weil ich dadurch fahren wollen
würde dann würde ich ja ganz einfach
ja dann bin ich ganz easy einfach so
hier durchfahren aber ich möchte darum
dürften deswegen das ist ja eigentlich
mein einziges ziel roboter stehen schon
wieder so viele laster ich habe schon
gar keinen bock mehr darauf hier sind
gar keine wollen alter ich fahre einfach
immer newport roben dann kommt einfach
widerlich ist das die beste taktik
einfach erstmal hier den bullen so ein
bisschen ihr einfach der polizei hier
erst mal so ein bisschen dann ja genau
weiß gar nicht ist es eigentlich
deutschland verboten dass man bundes
sagt wenn ja tut es mir leid das ist
hier künstler freiheit weil hier der
polizei hier so ein bisschen respekt
einflößenden von wegen guck mal hier ich
fahre die latte an roben ich kirche nie
irgendwas und jetzt kommen sie langsam
und jetzt mache ich einfach direkt gegen
die laterne mein ziel für diese folge
ist mehr als 20 sekunden dann höre ich
direkt auf mit dem video das ist echt
mal mein großes ziel dass das mehr als
20 sekunden zwölfter anders jetzt also
ich muss noch acht sekunden mehr
schaffen ich mich damit den posten los
kleines auto diese musik ist auch
überhaupt nicht nervös oder so ich hoffe
dass ruckelt nicht also ich sehe dass
gattin dem bildschirm so ein bisschen
das ganze ein bisschen ruckeln ich nehme
das ganze mit reflektor auf ich hoffe
einfach dass es nicht ruckelt bei euch
oder zumindest nur ein bisschen und wenn
ja dann
nehmt euren cookie und schmerzen in den
ofen und schenken mir ich weiß nicht was
gesagt hat okay ich glaube das ist
richtig nach der 20
bleibt bei der old school tagtäglich
versmold schild rum und dann drehe ich
wieder meinen üblichen download hier auf
dem boden wo ich erst mal alle
polizeiwagen austrägt ok ich glaube ich
habe ich glaube ich habe im gefühl ich
habe im gefühl dass das eine
interessante rolle scheiße doch wir
müssen uns einfach wieder am anfang so
schön hier um die kurve schön hier den
donut machen das geklappt so bayr
erstmal vernetzt dann fahre ich hier
oben hier und jetzt wieder ich hier an
den ganzen laster vorbei jetzt fahre ich
diesmal uhr war es gehe hier um eine
kurve nein jetzt 17
ok ich kann jetzt das video aufhören
aber irgendwie war das relativ wie das
heißt ich mache jetzt einfach mal so
wieder hier den download anstatt also
die taktik kann ich euch echt 19 herzen
lägen das land ans herzen und ich glaube
ans herz legen dass die reform dieses
mal stellt raumfahrt dann hier diesen
download was halt auch circa zehn mal
klappt von 100 versuchen ein sind wie
sie sagt ich zehn von 100 versuchen
anstatt einfach so schön und die monroe
dürften dann reden wir
hier eine kleine kurve fahren danach ihr
rum kommt von unten noch eine odernähe
und es hat dann fahren wir hier wieder
um die ecke
dann drehe ich jetzt aber mal hier die
kurve hier denke ich ja weg ist an bord
wir machen es mal wieder so wir fahren
jetzt um die mall und das vorhin war der
extrem gute taktik also ich kann nicht
sagen wenn dieser download klappt dann
geht danach dann habe ich danach direkt
9 high score du hier um die kurve jetzt
hier den dörner das sieht sehr gut aus
mit dem dauert jetzt fahren wir hier rum
jetzt kommt von unten einer jetzt fahren
wir hier um die tannenbäume rum jetzt
drehen wir hinten die kurve jetzt kommt
wahrscheinlich einer von der seite aber
die kriegen mich allerdings jetzt fahren
wir noch mal rum war dass ich jetzt hier
rum und um die mond um die mall und die
malta das gibt einen highscore das wird
ein weltstar
das wird ein world record zickig dieses
dings leute hier ich möchte hier nicht
irgendwie mich strafbar mache aber alter
was geht er mit mir ab alter was ist
denn los mit mir ich mache hier einfach
was geht alter oha vielleicht dem kind
von euch sind bestimmt auch viele dabei
die einfach war wie kind habe ich darum
gedriftet bin alter was geht denn ich
bin richtig stolz auf meine fahrers gilt
gerade genauso wie übrigens auch in
realer persona wer mir bei meinen folgt
oder bei twitter der kennt ihr diese
videos wenn ich im stau stehe ich drehe
jetzt erstmal hier meine runden auf der
spur geblieben halter dieses spiel macht
süchtig ich habe richtig bock auf dieses
spiel so ich habe das am anfang nicht so
richtig verstand weil ich wusste wie man
gas gibt und wie man lenkt und so aber
jetzt jetzt ist mit allen
relativ simpel zu verstehen aber an mir
was halt manchmal heizkörper 8 sekunden
und ich kann ich drüber weg aber jetzt
habe ich halt echt diese eine strecke
die ich immer wieder fahre und es läuft
freundes läuft ich habe schon wieder 23
sekunden am anfang gesagt bei 20
sekunden auf und jetzt rasuli ich
einfach diese sehr auf jeweils einer
minute aber
um die mall und jetzt ist der donut
wieder am start
diese beiden komischen leute in die
keine polizei sind wir um die ecke ab um
die mall rom jetzt wieder einen
donauausbau oder geil gewesen wenn ich
einfach durch die beiden durch gefahren
wäre
okay okay der donut klappt der dort
klappt und wenn es jetzt neue high score
wird dann höre ich definitiv auf mit dem
video weil ich möchte dass ja nicht so
lange spielen ich dass ich irgendwann
später keinen bock mehr drauf habe ich
hab echt angst dass das bei euch richtig
viel ruckelt verdammte scheiße wenn ich
das nämlich wäre das ganze bild ja auch
auf meinem imac hier und da sich das
ganze los ist ob das extrem ruckelt
einfach denn ich werde es in zukunft
nicht einfach mit einer elgato game
capture karte an irgendwie aufnehmen das
ipad dann irgendwie daran schließt aber
erst mal ist das jetzt der letzte raum
den ich für dieses video machte weil ich
sehe schon dass das ganze video wieder
den rahmen sprengt ich wollte mich
anfangs gedacht du musst ja ich muss ein
bisschen vorproduzieren weil ich über
das wochenende über karneval und soja in
köln bin deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
okay kommen zuletzt diesen ein blitz
diese eventuell einem drei minuten video
hoch weil dieses ganze bearbeiten dort
auch immer so extrem lange aber jetzt
ist auch schon so dass das ganze hier
schon wieder den rahmen sprengen
deswegen würde ich sagen meine lieben
freunde ich gucke schon die ganze zeit
weiterhin auf dem bildschirm möchte man
noch einmal heiß zu machen möchte wenn
es euch gefallen hat und wenn euch diese
app sachen gefallen also ich sehe es ja
an den klicks oder an den bewertungen
das euch diese apps die spieler immer
extrem gefallen
ich könnte nur noch ein bisschen was
machen an der flüssigkeit hatte jemand
irgendwelche erfahrungen oder
irgendwelche empfehlungen für mich dann
könnt ihr mir das gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv über eine bewertung freuen
ich versuche gerade diese diese nennt
card so lange wie möglich in die länge
zu stecken weil ich jetzt tot bin
und dann will ich sagen meine liebe
freunde ich hoffe euch als gefallen und
wir sind zum nächsten video wieder zu